speziell geht es richtig erscheint da
wird durch ein menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßen mal mein name ist
flughafen einer lieben freundin
heute werden wieder gehirnzellen
zerstört denn wir reagieren heute
gemeinsam auf das video ich bin
prinzipiell die batgirl rapperin von
welcher serie hilf mir natürlich dass
dieser sie scheiße immer in köln spielt
wo im alter das ist ein amg alles easy
aber man sollte ja nicht ein buch nach
dem cover wir hören mal ein bisschen
weiter
ich checke jetzt erst dass sie über ein
bereits bestehendes lied rappt ich
dachte erst dass sie diesen text
zumindest selbst geschrieben hätte und
sich jetzt gerade irgendwie ausprobiert
weil sie die nächsten die eine show
hatte und deswegen macht sie das jetzt
alles vom spiegel bleibt aber es gibt
nicht mal ihr eigener rap song als ich
bin noch viel mehr beeindruckt jetzt von
dir pc
[Musik]
das ist jetzt die mutter hat man denkt
aber halt wirklich losgeht wenn man
diese pcl gesehen hat denkt man sich
erstmal dass ihre mutter ja vielleicht
eher so mit bier und kippe aber als sie
sieht ja echt nach einer vernünftigen
mama aus also ich bin gespannt was jetzt
der pc sagt
[Musik]
jeden tag um die mutter sagt hayes viel
zu laut und was sagt die pc games sogar
also soll das ja schon wieder klassen
rumlaufen aber das ist doch die
argumentation die sollte man einfach
thema bringen klassenarbeiten abitur uni
jena.de gipfel lux denn da der kriege
ich kein fan ja gar nichts keine kohle
nix was soll ich da muss rauskommen das
werde ich auch tun werden ist so viel
grün
ich weiß wie ich weiß ich was ich darauf
sagen soll das ist furchtbar bis die lg
ist meine absolute neue beste
lieblingskünstler aller zeiten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich habe jetzt keinen erfolg
mehrfach pro kopf noch du machst es
alleine ich habe dafür ist kein er es
mir sowieso ist die lg dein vater ist
der asozialen dieser situation gerade
was ihr an der stelle auf jeden fall
auch mal wieder sagen möchte ich weiß es
faktoren ab meine kommentare mein lachen
und allgemeinem eine komplette reaktion
richtig sich selbstverständlich nicht in
die richtigen schauspieler hinter den
rollen sondern lediglich gegen die
gespielte rolle und das ist das worüber
ich mich lustig mache also ich möchte
nicht dass irgendjemand hier geheiratet
wird oder sich beleidigt führt durch
meine kommentare zu sein lena zu sein
und so wie meine
lena jansen das hört sich an nach seiner
frau die im blumengeschäft hat aber ich
halte es weiterhin groß rauskommen
werden die alle sehen ja stimmt ist sie
jetzt ich dachte die also ich wusste das
natürlich meinen sie ist meine absolute
lieblingsstadt rapperin also jetzt mal
wieder top ich dachte wirklich sie heißt
pcl aber etwas macht halt in die
aussprache lena für den kuss zwischen
timo und mutter nicht einfach hinnehmen
denn was uns hat rache geschworen
[Musik]
was für einen kursgewinn haben wie
festgenommen habe ich den knall nicht
dabei und süchten gerade raus bekommen
und ich habe richtig fertiggemacht geht
gerade auf das video mit den zwei heißt
jungs kann nur geil wenn mich das erste
mal ins netz stellen werden sich alle
wundern wenn ich richtig durchstarten
tour
[Applaus]
ich bin ich aber halt echt gespannt auf
das video es richtiger scheint da wird
durch ein
ich bin auf jeden
meine gehirnzellen mir so leid
andrea berg helene fischer sind alles
nur dämliche also ich kann das niveau
halten irgendwo mehr finden und machen
sich so scheiße aber wichtig dass jetzt
zwei kay one poster hängen
das ist irgendwie raus trägt oder so
dann hast du nicht über alles da wird
nie wieder was wir zu tun haben wollen
ja ist timo jetzt in der situation was
lena nicht ahnt ihr gestriger fehltritt
bleibt auch vor timo nicht lange
verborgen
haben die da noch so
ihr video weitergedreht vielleicht
sollte die pc elliot in eine andere
branche einsteigen musik haben uns so
was ist der tumor ist dass die schwester
lucy scheißdreck anlehnen doch wie kommt
so richtig höflich an fragte was los sei
strikt anlegen doch das ist in diesem
moment ist alles gelogen ihre eltern
sind am leben doch kennen drogenopfer
sieg in hose wenigstens mädchen
eigentlich hatte ich raff gar nichts
mehr weil sein scheint hat diese pc
elliott ihren ganzen coolen rapper
freunden gesagt dass ihre eltern tot
sind und dass sie selber früher drogen
genommen hat und blabla und irgendwie im
knast war mit sich der mit der polizei
geschlagen hatte keine ahnung und der
timo hier also anscheinend ihr freund
hat sie gerade mal vor allen leuten
auffliegen lassen also timo da kam auf
jeden fall mal klatschen als ich gesehen
habe
mit diesen zwei typen in diesem video
home gemacht hat ich kotzen können ich
bin fertig mit dir
trotzdem können also der timo muss
ehrlich sagen der aussprache passt der
eigentlich ganz cool zu erleben habe ich
weiß es wirklich nicht
es tut mir so leid er ist sogar
verschreckt direkt abgehauen
ach du heilige scheiße ich glaube dass
sie den timo geküsst hat ich checke aber
auch ehrlich gesagt gar nix mehr
nein wir haben doch beide das gleiche
ziel wir wollen beide tiere aus diesem
loch raus und schneiden das geht doch
nur mal mehr zusammenhalten
also die unterhaltung muss man wirklich
sagen jetzt eigentlich gerade ganz schön
das sind so zwei schwestern die eine ist
halt ja voll die trainerin und die
andere ist speziell jetzt aber dass
natürlich die schwester von der pc
elliott was mit dem freund von der piste
elliott gehabt haben soll macht die lage
jetzt natürlich nicht besser
ich bin ganz stolz auf mich dass ich den
satz vernünftig rausgekriegt hat obwohl
meine ganzen gehirnzellen abgestorben
sind hague im euro system nicht zu
entschuldigen
[Musik]
jetzt verstehe ich absolut gar nichts
mehr ich glaube dass das sich jetzt eine
aktion einfach von timo ist um seiner
ex-freundin pcl jetzt eins auszuwischen
aber wir schauen mal weiter ich fühle
mich so als mädchen soll affenkäfig
geschoss worden und verstehe überhaupt
nicht was abgehen oder was die mir
mitteilen wollen die drei sind so ein
bisschen wie das bermuda-dreieck da das
ist ja so ein ort in südamerika da
verschwinden ganz plötzlich irgendwie
mal schiffe bei denen verschwinden dann
die gehirnzellen wenn man da drin ist
ich möchte an der stelle gar nicht mehr
weiter auf das video hier reagieren weil
meine ganzen gehirnzellen sind eh schon
weg von daher würde ich das heute wieder
der stadt jetzt auch beenden wenn euch
meine reaktion auf chris elliott palin
jansen wenn ich meine reaktion gefallen
hat dann das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video jeder schreibt er ohne
die kommentare auf pcl jay auch eure
lieblings rapperin ist abonniert main
kanal falls sie noch kein teil der luchs
usaid ist es kostenlos und dadurch
verpasste keine videos mehr und falschen
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf das symbol
links klicken das ist nämlich die glocke
und wenn ihr unter dem video da drauf
klickt bekommt ihr sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen eine benachrichtigung
auf euer handy
[Musik]